نعم ، هل تعلم أنني أمضيت آه
بعض أمسيات الأمس نوعًا ما
أقوم بالرياضيات أثناء إجراء
هذه الدراسات حقًا في محاولة لمعرفة ما
كان يتحدث عنه وما
زال بعضها غير منطقي ، لذا
أه تعلم
أننا اتصلنا به  أه أه هو وأنا تحدثنا
لفترة من الوقت نتصفح هذه
الأرقام حقًا وبعد ذلك بفترة وجيزة
نشر هذه
التغريدة هذه السلسلة من التغريدات بشكل أساسي
لتوضيح ما
قاله وأعتقد أن هذا مهم
لأنني أعتقد أن ما سمعه الناس
في المؤتمر الصحفي  في يوم الأحد ، كان
البحث عما إذا كان مائة شخص
قد تناولوا هذا العلاج ، حيث كان 35 شخصًا
سينجون ، وإلا
لما نجوا ، هذا ما
تركه الناس نوعًا ما وهذا
بالتأكيد يبدو
مثيرًا للإعجاب ، لكن هذا ليس حقًا
ما أظهرته الدراسة على الإطلاق وأعتقد
أن هذا  ما كان الدكتور هان يعتذر نوعًا ما
عن تحريف تلك
البيانات ،
دعني أريكم هذا بسرعة ، أعلم
أن الكثير من الرياضيات للصباح ولكن
دعني أريكم هذا لأنني
أعتقد أنه من
المهم حقًا أن أمضيت الكثير من الوقت في النظر
إلى دراسة Mayo Clinic
أمس ويمكننا أن نظهر لكم هنا 35000 شخص
تقريبًا تمت دراستهم ، وكانت
هذه بيانات جديدة تم تقديمها إلى
إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
يقولون في وقت متأخر من ليلة الجمعة وحتى يوم
السبت ، لذلك هذه هي البيانات الجديدة التي تم تقديمها إلى إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA).  ما الذي كانوا
يستخدمونه في المؤتمر الصحفي يوم الأحد ،
ولكن هذا ما يُظهر أنه
تمت دراسة 35000 شخص إذا حصلت على جرعة عالية
من مصل النقاهة ، كان هناك
8.9
معدل وفيات بعد أسبوع من وفاة 8.9 من الأشخاص
مقابل الجرعة المنخفضة 13.7
لذا بدلاً من قول  35 شخصًا آخرين
سيبقون على قيد الحياة بعد
لي أسبوعًا ، سيكون أقرب إلى خمسة أشخاص
قد ينجون بعد أسبوع
الآن لم تتم مقارنة أي من هذه المجموعات من
الأشخاص مع
العلاج الوهمي مقارنة بمجموعة من
الأشخاص الذين لم
يتلقوا مصل النقاهة على الإطلاق.
لا
نعرف هل هذا حقًا مصل النقاهة ، هل
هو شيء آخر ،
دعني أريكم عندما نظرنا إلى
البيانات عن كثب قليلاً وجدنا أن
الأشخاص في هذه المجموعات كانوا يحصلون عليها أيضًا
الأدوية الأخرى
التي كانوا يحصلون عليها من المنشطات كانوا
يحصلون عليها ،
لذا فأنت تعلم أن ما يقرب من نصف الأشخاص
كانوا يحصلون على المنشطات ، لذا هل كانت
المنشطات
هي مصل النقاهة الذي لا
تعرفه
ولهذا السبب التجارب العشوائية الخاضعة للرقابة
ضرورية وهؤلاء الملاذون '  لم
يتم إنجازه بعد وأعتقد أن هذا هو
النقد